this is what I believe and I'm willing
to die for it
greatness is not this wonderful esoteric
illusive godlike feature that only the
special among us will ever taste you
know it's something that truly exists in
all of us
believe in yourself even when no one
else does
life is not a parabolic curve doesn't go
straight up a lot of lumps a lot of
bumps a lot of throttling up a lot of
throttling down I have never yet met a
successful person that hasn't had to
overcome either little or a lot of
adversity in his or her life
I offered a new life and your life have
you lived in the cheap seats watching
the game not in it many of you as I have
been as I am are where you are in your
life based upon what you believe and
it's not just what you think you believe
on the surface it's also your shadow
beliefs that are holding you back from
moving into the life that you believe
you deserve
beliefs are what make the difference
between a lifetime of joyous
contribution and one of misery and
devastation beliefs are what separate a
Mother Teresa from a Charles Manson
beliefs will cause some individuals to
become heroes while others lead lives of
quiet desperation see the power of
beliefs is virtually unlimited our
beliefs can literally create or destroy
beliefs are not merely matters of
emotion or action they can literally
change our bodies in a matter of moments
so what exactly is a belief this thing
that's so powerful
basically it's simply a feeling of
certainty about what something means
it's a feeling that's supported by what
we call references by life experiences
that hold that belief up think of an
idea as a tabletop with no legs there's
nothing that's supported it's not solid
it becomes a belief the day you put legs
underneath that tabletop now it's
supported now it's solid now you feel
certain and all personal breakthroughs
we must remember begin with the change
in our beliefs when your desires are
different from your beliefs you will
always manifest what you believe
[Music]
when a seed is planted in the ground all
you can do is watering you cannot
control the sunshine you cannot control
the weather and you cannot control what
the locusts will come and try to destroy
it all you can do is plant your seed in
the ground water it and believe the most
important thing self confidence without
that skill and I use the word skill
intentionally without that skill we are
useless because when you lose sight and
belief in yourself we're done for I use
the definition of self-confidence to be
the ability or the belief to believe in
yourself to come to accomplish any task
no matter the odds
no matter the difficulty no matter the
adversity the belief that you can
accomplish it self confidence
who it begins here and it ends here this
is what the process of success and
growth is all about it has to be rooted
in belief you need to believe truly
believe and the development of a
stronger belief system is a process it
doesn't just explode overnight right if
my goal is to make it to the other side
of the room the belief is a long way
away and I can't make it in one step
through right but I can take one step
and here's what that step allowed me to
do to believe in one
belief said what do you believe in you
believe that you must ultimately achieve
this goal unswervingly and that belief
creates your reality because you begin
to see the whole world differently a lot
of expectations
you constantly expect that everything
that happens is part of a plan to help
bring you towards your goal the law of
attraction when you attract you attract
people ideas and circumstances into your
life to help you to achieve your most
important goal and so all you need to do
to raise your self-confidence your
self-esteem and your level of attainment
high is to have an absolutely crystal
clear goal and work on it every single
day you have to reprogram your mind you
have to condition your mind to get
yourself to believe that hey it's just a
matter of time baby I'm gonna hit that
mark you can't see it you can't touch it
you don't know that it's real so they're
ruling your mind but in your mind you
tell it with your imagination you know
it to happen impossible is nothing what
are you how you hang in there during the
hard difficult times less you must have
faith you've got to believe in yourself
you better believe in your abilities you
got to believe in your service your
company your ideas unquestionably you
got to have faith and that faith gives
you patience that's not gonna happen as
quickly as you want it to happen a lot
of things gonna happen that will catch
you off guard and so therefore you've
got to deal with and handle it as it
comes
but that faith and patience drives you
into action you've got to keep moving
and keep plugging away leave believe
believe believe believe believe
impossible is nothing
[Music]